the security guard can't even talk the
concierge looks at me and he says yeah
like she's with me
she's here to see me
um this is weird so I go let Ellie out
my dog I go back upstairs and I call the
concierge and I say hey she needs to
leave just so you know she will be
perceived as a threat I will call the
cops and
um she needs to be escorted out of the
building and he then tells me that oh
and I say that she is stalking me now
because what else am I supposed to think
if this lady seemingly has no
relationship with the security guard
other than
there is after the show he also took her
side after the show
um which is weird why would you take
this inside of a crazy lady over a
resident
all right call me crazy okay